welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's keynote presentation
nucleic acid detection with CRISPR
Diagnostics presented by dr. omar abu
dali who is an MIT McGovern Institute
Fellow and dr. Jonathan Guttenberg who's
also a MIT McGovern Institute fellow
my name is Xavier courtiers and I will
be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars now before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation and if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. Alberto yang
and dr. Gutenberg I will now turn the
presentation over to them babe thank you
for the introduction so hmm
Jonathan I will be talking about a lot
of our work that we did as graduate
students and dr. Fung Jones lab at the
Broad Institute I will sort of speak for
the first half about sort of the early
Christopher discovery work and
development of the Sherlock technology
for Diagnostics and then Jonathan will
close in the second half with more of
our sort of next-generation feature
development and where we're going with
the platform so to dive in I just want
to have a conflict of interest
disclosure so John and I are both
cofounders of Sherlock Biosciences which
is commercializing mr. lock platform as
well as advisors for beam therapeutics
so so a lot of the work that we do is
really motivated by looking towards
nature for tool development and nature
has been really remarkable
you know adapting unique systems and
proteins for all sorts of sort of
environmental challenges that bacteria
and other organisms are exposed to and
just to see how rich of an resource
nature can be we can look at many
examples where you know normal sort of
systems in these organisms can be
adapted for really powerful applications
including sort of the original you know
innate immune systems that were found in
bacteria restriction enzymes which are
really useful for even about their
biology and cloning you know for us a
proteins enzymes are useful for energy
or even cleaning like cellulase and even
viral vectors for gene therapy and
optogenetics for modulating the nervous
system and of course what we're here to
talk about today the CRISPR system which
is an incredible adaptive immune system
of bacteria has been sort of ushering a
revolution or genome editing and so you
know one of the questions for us is how
can we discover new CRISPR tools and
things that might be useful or totally
new applications for example diagnostics
and so when Johnson I first started in
the lab there's you know everyone was
really excited about cassadine and how
cassadine could use our programmable DNA
cleavage and we have this really
interesting question of whether the
caste 9 was only thing that was there so
you know of course the CRISPR system is
very diverse as you can see here these
all these different you know proteins
and colors represent the diversity of
enzymes in the CRISPR universe and of
course caste 9 if you zoom in at the
bottom is really just a small slice of
this universe and so we have a question
of whether we can find more enzymes like
caste lying that are simple just a
single protein versus these other
systems which have many proteins and
that can be adaptable for different
technology purposes so to do that we can
simplify all that diversity on the last
slide and to really sort of condense set
of features and here you can see the
different classes sort of expression and
a firends adaptation proteins are kind
of colored and what's really interesting
is if you look at the adaptation
which are shown in blue they actually
tend to be the most conserved enzymes
out of all CRISPR systems and so we can
actually take advantage of the
conservation to pull out new systems and
so we thought could we take test1 and
use that as a seed for a computational
program that could look in every
bacterial genome that's been sequenced
for new systems and so the idea here is
we can take house 1 and search bacterial
genomes for every single sequence or
area that contains case 1 and then we
can look around the cast 1 in the
genomes for other proteins that might be
near it and start to sort of cluster
those proteins and look for proteins
that tend to be enriched near cast 1 and
using that enrichment we can insert the
hypothesized what a CRISPR system would
look like around cast 1 and then we can
build new CRISPR families from that and
so and so we can pull out the candidates
from this pipeline and we can sort of
analyze what they look like and so when
we did this analysis we actually found
many new candidate systems that were
sort of centered around cast 1 and so
one of the ones was this type 5 a pre
friend which is not called CPF one or
test 12 I was really exciting it was the
first single sort of protein beyond
cassadine that was shown to be useful
for programmable DNA cutting and genome
editing and then these type 5b and type
5 C's or caste 12 being
sofc which are also useful for DNA
genome editing and then what was perhaps
most exciting was this last one this
type six locus because this sort of pink
purple protein CTC - which is now known
as caste 13 actually looked like a cut
RNA instead of DNA and the reason we
suspected that is because the c2 c2
enzyme has these domains shown in dark
purple called - domains which are
typically RNA stone means is that en ace
domains and so we did a lot of work on
both in bacterium biochemically to
really publish a paper showing that CGC
- or no it's called tester keen a it was
actually a programmable RNA cutting
enzyme
rnase and the way it works is shown in
the slide where essentially there's a
single test or key protein methane
complex with a guide RNA and there's
guard RNA is essentially primed for
cleaving invading RNA is like a phage
RNA and in cleave the RNA genomes of
these invading sort of viruses and the
idea here is instead of cleaving a
single cut like caste 9 it will generate
multiple cuts in single-stranded regions
of an RNA and it's actually eventually
degrade RNAs
so it's a very powerful enzyme that does
a lot more than just a single cut which
is what made test 13 really unique and
where that becomes especially powerful
for diagnostic applications is this
additional feature of the biochemistry
which is this idea of promiscuous
cleavage or collateral leakage and what
we found was that when we incubated
castor team but without a target so the
guide RNA had no target you would
obviously ICAST our team and see no
cleavage of any RNAs and solution even
if this green RNA is not targeted by the
guy so it would just stay intact but
what we found is when you added the
target RNA such that the guide RNA would
recognize it and activate castor teen we
saw not only cleavage of this black
target RNA but also cleavage of other
RNAs and solution that were not
complementary to the guide so it looked
like basically the presence of a target
could activate castor teen and in castor
keen would just chew up any RNAs in
solution and we realized that that
activation activity could be is
essentially reporting on the presence of
a nucleic acid target and in essence we
found maybe we could turn that into a
diagnostic so the way we tried to adopt
this for Diagnostics was we realized if
we added an RNA reporter with a four
fluorescent probe on one end of the
quencher on the other this RNA probe
would be not fluorescent though in
cleaved you would separate the floor
four from the clencher and you get
fluorescence
and so the idea here is if there's a
blue RNA in a sea of orange RNAs that
you want to detect you could design a
guide RNA forecaster team that detects
it and when that guide RNA binds to the
target and activates caster team you in
cleavage these reporter RNAs which
release fluorescence and that worked
fairly well we were able to get sort of
you know into the low picomolar maybe
high femtomolar range of detection and
so that's pretty neat but it's still you
know on the order of millions hundreds
of millions of molecules per microliter
and so for a lot of clinical
applications where you require higher
sensitivity you actually need lower
detection limits and so we developed a
way to sort of improve upon this initial
collateral detection and so we came up
with this technology which we
essentially had this backronym Sherlock
that we called it but the idea here is
you can take in DNA or RNA and you can
isothermally amplify it using this
technology called recombination rates
amplification and RPA is it's you can
kind of think of it like PCR but instead
of needing to thermally cycle the steps
you can actually use enzymes to replace
those steps so there's a combination
that can heal the primers the polymerase
that can extend the primers and so the
whole amplification actually operates at
37°
so at a single temperature which makes
this really convenient then through the
amplification we add t7 transcription
candles so that we can transcribe down
to five DNA into RNA and then this RNA
can of course then be sent by your
collateral detection method and what's
really great about this sherlock
approach is all these steps can operate
in a single reaction so they're all
compatible they all offer that 37
degrees so it's actually just a single
step really simple buffer that can
detect nucleic acids and so when we
tried this out what we found is of
course castor teen by itself like I said
had low picomolar sensitivity so this
scale is an atom molar and atom molar is
10 to the minus 18
and to Anna molar which is at the right
end of this x-axis is about single
molecule sensitivity single molecule per
microliter sensitivity so when we add
this pre amplification approach on the
last slide which is the Sherlock
technology you see that the whole curve
comes up and we actually can get down
the to add a molar detection and this is
on RNA but we can also do this on DNA as
well so the really powerful method that
gets you quick amplification and all of
these assays are you know about an hour
so that was a really great first
demonstration that the technology works
on synthetic DNA or RNA and we got
really excited about what applications
and clinical Diagnostics could we then
go after with this platform and so you
know molecular diagnostics are really
enough in coming area you know the
molecular diagnostics tend to focus on
proteins and sensing proteins using
antibody based assays nucleic acids even
better because it's easier to design an
assay just design a guide RNA or you
know probes and you know there are a lot
of applications for nucleic acid
diagnostics including viral detection
you know being able to detect bacteria
like in sepsis you know a lot of efforts
to make these types of assays really
portable which will even think about
with Sherlock as well as even genotyping
detecting cancer and even beyond
healthcare there's a lot of agricultural
applications as well so on the next you
know set of slides I'm going to talk
about a few of these areas that we've
applied Sherlock so the first area we
kind of wanted to do was zika detection
because at the time a couple years ago
this was a very big problem and it still
is a problem now and so what we did is
we packaged zika fragments and to
lentiviral articles so we could work
with the viral articles and we showed
that with just a simple heating stuff we
could break open the particles and then
put them into a sherlock workflow and
get detection in less than an hour and
so we were able to actually get down to
two animal or viral particles which is a
single particle per test and then we
could detect Zika very specifically so
dengue has similar sequence to Zika and
so it shows that our
our test is very specific we also did
this for human samples so we took human
serum or urine from patients that were
infected with Zika and we could actually
put them also through the Sherlock
workflow and we found that we could get
close to single molecule zika detection
you know so each each bar here is a
different patient and they had different
sort of lonesome Zika in their bodies
and so we have a certain range of
concentrations we were able to detect in
these people so I was really great and
then we also wanted to show that we
could theoretically make this a portable
test so in our early versions of
portable Sherlock we actually could
freeze dry the castor Keene detection
reaction on pieces of paper and then
reconstitute the sample on those pieces
of paper and we found that we could
still get into the atom molar levels
down to 20 out of over 10 Zika particles
per test so that was also really
promising
as well now lastly for these early
applications we also wanted to show that
we can do very good specificity on
nucleic acid and so I mentioned a little
bit earlier though you know were able to
distinguish eco bursts dengue which
those target expensive differ by maybe
four or five you know positions but we
wondered whether we could detect a
single mutation and so an interesting
application for that is cancer mutations
and cell-free key made from the blood so
that you could just do liquid biopsies
and if the tech communications coming
from tumors a common mutation is the
v600e mutation in PRF which is you know
present in melanoma and so we designed
the Sherlock assay that could detect
this mutation as showing the sequence is
shown here and we of course had a crisp
RNA that detects the wild type II raft
which is a normal signal and also the
mutant sensing which is the tumor
oncogenic version and the samples we had
had varying levels of the v600e mutation
so as shown here on this graph there is
zero percent 0.1 percent 1 percent and 5
percent loads and so you know the blood
obviously you know if you have a lot of
tumor
have a higher mutation load and the
tumour is you know maybe earlier in its
growth the other lower concentration of
mutation so with the wild I'm sensing
crisp RNA we of course get detection for
all those conditions because there's a
large amount of the wild type always
present but for the mutation you can see
we see a dose-dependent increase in the
in the signal and so this allows us to
calibrate sort of signature for the
tumor where we can actually detect a
single mutation which I think is really
powerful because these CRISPR enzymes
are so sensitive to mutations which is
what makes them so specific for chemo
meditating or basically leveraging that
specificity for plate acid detection now
which is really uh I think powerful so
so that was our first sort of iteration
of Sherlock and you know a lot of our
work in the past year year and a half
has been how could we make sure like
even better even more portable and so
Jonathan is actually going to go over
that work now so I'd like to bring him
on to the presentation great thanks Omar
for that great outline of the show on
technology and once we had completed
this initial Sherlock development we
asked ourselves how can we make the
Sherlock technology more useful so we
focused on three areas multiplexing
being able to actually read out multiple
different analytes in a single reaction
quantitation being able to measure not
just a presence or absence but the
actual amount of a sample interaction
and a visual readout how can we actually
create a totally instant free platform
that doesn't rely on any sort of ear at
all
so first how can we detect multiple
targets simultaneously and this approach
really comes from the idea of this
diversity that Omar discussed that there
are many different types of enzymes out
there that can do this cleavage so you
want to find orthogonal casts or teen
enzymes to explore new families as well
as use test twelve enzymes I can cut DNA
instead of RNA which allows us to read
out both DNA and RNA in our reporter VM
so the cat's 13 family is a very diverse
set of enzymes you can see here that not
only are there counselor J's which we
initially discovered that we also
subsequently discovered cast 13 seized
and cast our GPS and these enzymes
differ in many different ways for
example to caster can be do not
associate with the cast one it has two
accessory enzymes for adaptation but one
thing that we wanted profile is how
these enzyme cut in a different way so
instead of assuming that all these
enzymes had just caught RNA we wanted to
profile which bases they would caught so
you can imagine that certain enzymes
would cut a and not you or G and not C
so what we did is we created reporters
that were home polymers each of aids
used G's and then we took a large
diversity of of castor DNA as well as
cast 13 B enzymes and acid I'm against
these four reporters and here you can
see that some enzymes actually do have
preached strong preferences in certain
directions for example the counselor ta
that we were using from lecture Kawada l
do you a counselor to nail over there on
the left has a very strong preference
for poly use however if you look at
other enzymes like PSM caste 13 b which
is a six from the left you can see that
it does not cut used but instead first
to cut aids so if you put these two
enzymes together in safe action and gave
these a new floor floor floor or
reporters different colors you'd be able
to read these out orthogonal we can
actually extend this concept even
further so instead of relying on single
bases we can actually look at
dinucleotide preferences so here we have
two nucleotides one after another with
DNA in the other areas so in those two
only suppose two nucleotides and here
you can see that this can even further
separate enzymes so if you look at LD
break a certain a and CCA caste are to
be initially when you look at the homo
polymers they both cut dudes but you can
actually see that LW a caste Virginia
will cut au while CCA counselors be will
cut you see instead and so this allows
us to actually have four different
enzymes you can see that kind of each a
different dynamically type lastly we can
actually
supplement the RNA cutting with Jeana
cutting as well so Omar mentioned CPF 1
which is later renamed the caste well
they which we discovered as part of this
expansion to new class new systems and
it was subsequently demonstrated that
cash flow they also had the collateral
cleavage
except of course because the DNA cut it
enzyme on DNA rather than RNA there is
one caveat which is that when just using
the enzyme alone it's actually much less
sensitive than the RNA cleaving enzymes
so here you can see LW a castor DNA and
PSF castor can be and they can find you
can actually detect a signal down to
about 1 that 1 million molecules for
about each of them but if you look at a
s castor caste 12a it's actually much
less sensitive now the important thing
is if we actually do pre-notification
beforehand so the entire sherlock
workflow then all of these enzymes are
capable of detecting that down to the
single molecule level which means that
they can actually all be used for
detection so what we wanted to do is
actually create a detection system that
could read out where things are thought
so we took three RNA cutting enzymes TSM
caste 13 b LW a caste 13 a CCA caste
certain V and Anse Castro a and we gave
them each a different floor for an RNA
or DNA reporter and then we each of them
target a different molecule Zika RNA
dengue RNA or the synthetic SS RNA one
or dsDNA one and we looked for detection
in each separate channel so in the
absence of any sort of target in the
solution you can see that we have no
detection of anything at all then if we
add in each target individually into a
reaction you can see that we can detect
each of them in their own channel and no
crossbar to other channels
lastly you can actually see that for
every possible combination of the 16
combinations that have either presence
or absence of the four target
we can actually detect that without any
sort of crosstalk so this allows us to
have a completely orthogonal way to look
up to four different colors and so for
different potential infectious diseases
or for different variants that we can
assay at the same reaction so our second
question was how can we actually
quantify sample concentration instead of
having a absence
presence marker so we actually came back
and looked at that our PA the comedy's
plumbers amplification because we wanted
to tune it so the isothermal
amplification wouldn't reach a regime
where it was not linear anymore so what
we did is we actually did our PA with
different amounts of primer to tune the
efficiency and when we found is that
when we use different amounts of primers
too much primer or too little primer
actually resulted in a non quantitative
regime however when we have just the
right amount of primer we could actually
detect multiple orders of magnitude so
we could actually distinguish between
orders of ten all the way up to ten
thousand molecules using just a very
tuned primer concentration which allows
us to have all these different assays
tuned for quantitative as well as binary
readout lastly we wanted to actually
generate a visual readout a method that
we could use to have an instrument
independent way of finding if a sample
was present or absent so what we turned
to was lateral flow strips akin to a
pregnancy like readout so those often
take a famine a biomolecule and have the
biotin attached to strip and we can
detect the fam by president of an anti
Pam antibody so what happens is that if
we take a famine biomolecule and put a
piece of RNA between them when there's
the presence of the target it'll cut
this apart
and so then when we put this on the
strip if there is no target so this is a
negative test where the reporter is
attacked it'll flow up and reach a
streptavidin line and it'll be stuck
there and then it will bind an anti Pham
antibody so it will
the antigen will trap the antibody at
that line now in the case that we
actually do have the target present and
their quarters cleaved a positive test
well then we won't be able to capture
all of that antibody and it'll actually
continue to flow out and flow to a
second antibody captured a lot this
allows us to turn any test that we could
normally do with fluorescence in the
original Sherlock publication into a lot
of flow based tests for example for our
Zika dose titration you can see that we
can actually turn our zekeyl detection
of RNA into a lateral flow by changing
the reporter and here you can see the
strong top band down to about 200
molecules and then for 20 and 10
molecules it's a little more difficult
to see here but we actually still have
quantitatively increased over the zero
control for these conditions so this
allows us to basically make a completely
portable test that can detect any
nucleic acid of interest so we wanted to
apply these new capabilities to samples
so let's touch on three things today one
is liquid biopsy of circulating DNA in
cancer via with our lateral flow assay
another one is direct Zika detection
without instrumentation or purification
and the last is an agricultural
application how can we genotype crops in
the field in a very rapid fashion so
first liquid biopsy detected lateral
flow how can we actually turn Sherlock
into a portable way of testing for
burden of mutations associated with
cancer so what we did is we actually
took liquid biopsy samples and have them
DNA extracted by our collaborators of
the Brigham and Women's Hospital and
then we can take that cell free DNA and
do rapid RPA and subsequent detection
and then we can treat it out by
fluorescence or bilateral flow so as all
more demonstrated with the initial
samples in our first paper we can be
very very sensitive to single mutation
so here we can sense the EGFR la-5 8 our
mutation you can see that our incensing
crispr RNA
is strong in the mutant condition but is
absent of the wild-type condition so
this is a fluorescence but if you
actually turn this test into a lateral
flow test you can still see that there's
a pronounced band in the mutant patient
for the crisp RNA that's not present for
the wild-type patient patient to make a
crisp RNA and you can see the
quantitation next to it and we actually
apply this to multiple different cancer
associated genotypes so here is an exon
19 deletion from EGFR as well so this
allows us to have a very portable method
for oncology that's minimally invasive
and could be done at a minute clinic or
a doctor's office
our second foray into rapid and direct
detection was in collaboration of pretty
savetti here at the broad and Cameron
mural and Katherine free sheet to member
for lab and he was about detecting Zika
in the field we had the cover of science
with her on this and that that's a
picture of the Zika virus in the dirt in
fields so it's a little tongue-in-cheek
but the idea was how can we detect Zika
not only in a very rapid fashion but
with minimal even extraction so first
what Cameron Katherine and parties did
is that they detected us using Sherlock
Zika and dengue virus from patient
panels can compare them to the
state-of-the-art controls so here are
samples that were deemed positive or
negative from the Altona test which is a
RT to PCR test for Zika and you can see
that the agree very well both on these
deccan samples as well as these dinging
samples or serum clip license and
culture dengue so this is very nice but
commonly for nucleic acid detection you
need to still extract those nucleic
acids so what Cameron Katherine did is
that they've developed a complementary
method to Sherlock called Hudson which
uses nucleus and activation and viral
and activation cheating steps so all the
requires is simple eating and a small
amount of buffer
no columns are complicated purifications
to extract nucleic acids and inactivate
nucleases that would cause the shock
test not to work
and then you can put that into Sherlock
and they demonstrated that this is a
compatible with many different common
bio matrices so here you can see that we
have PBS and serum and I mean serum you
can still detect up to about 100
molecules without purification in saliva
you can detect down for basically single
molecules you still and also you can do
the same with urine so here we can
essentially detect the presence of any
sort of bio matrix and nucleic acids
inside of that so they wanted to apply
this to example the flaviviruses Zika
and dengue that they had so what they
did is they took these unpurified
samples and they you took patients here
and healthy serum and what you can see
is that they have substantially
increased fluorescence for the patient
serum versus the healthy serum and the
patient's liver versus the healthy
saliva and not only was this combated
with fluorescence but it was also
compatible with lateral flow so here you
can see that for the patients here in
patients fly the samples we can get
strong top bands that don't appear in a
healthy saliva healthy serum or no input
bands they also developed a test for
pamphlet viruses so using Universal RPE
primers you can actually determine the
presence of zika dengue West Nile and
yellow fever so by designing guides and
each of these different flaviviruses you
can actually determine orthogonal a the
presence of each of them without
detecting the others so of course in
combination with our fluorescents our
multiplexing that I discussed earlier
you can imagine a in sample rapid test
for all of these different potential
cloudy viruses and you can see that they
are totally orthogonal these are samples
with actually two 5a viruses per you can
see that it the actual detection matches
exactly what the input samples were even
beyond this we can detect single based
mutations in Zika patient samples so in
the evolution of Zika the honduras
strain is more diversion from the
Dominican Republic in United States
trains and you can actually detect the
Pres
of these different single based based
mutations that cause them to be defined
so you can actually see that patients
with with samples from the Dominican
Republic versus the USA or Honduras
correspond to their actual mutation
samples compared to the ancestral seed
stock so we can actually genotype
different strains to figure out where
they're from but even beyond that we can
actually do genotyping to figure out
important features for pathology so many
people think of Zika as being strongly
related with microcephaly but there's
actually the evolution of a single
mutation in Zika that contributes to
this microcephaly phenotype so we can
actually potentially just check that so
during this study this mutation was
found and the nice thing about the
Sherlock platform is because it's so
programmable and so our bust we can
actually design the samples the CRISPR
neighs the RPI primers and designed an
entire essay and test it we in under a
week time so what Cameron Katherine did
is they actually designed CRISPR neighs
against the target as well as the
ancestral stocks and you can see that
the ancestral stocks and target stocks
can be distinguished based on the
presence of these mutations and the
microcephaly associate mutation can even
be read out in the lateral flow effect
format so you can see the derivative and
seed blocks all have the derivative but
not the ancestral and vice versa so we
can actually find relevant mutations
very rapidly and without instrumentation
lastly we can apply this to agricultural
phenotyping literally in the field in
situations where you may want to rapidly
look for pathogens or other plant
properties so what we did is we wanted
to look for the presence of Roundup
Ready crops this is the cp4 epsps gene
and we want to compare that presence to
the lectin gene which should be present
in all soybeans so we took soybean
samples and grandma
a rapid extraction assay and we found
that we could actually detect
substantially more of the epsps signal
in these samples but only when the GMO
was present so we actually took a rapid
G DNA extraction and we took from beans
the rapid our PA did a 20-minute test or
chain reaction and applied lava flow
detection and we were able to actually
within 30 minutes be able to detect the
presence of the Roundup Ready gene in
these soybeans compared to the wild type
and this was substantially increased
when we quantified it so here you can
see that we've improved on many
applications and properties of the
schlock platform we've increased
multiplexing by using multiple different
enzymes we improved with quantitation by
20 primers we use lateral flow detection
to actually create a complete official
readout we be able to use amplification
to detect additional signal using cm6
which is discussed in our paper and we
can actually do direct detection with
crude samples using Hudson so this in
all creates a very portable and rapid
pipeline for detecting nucleic acids
across multiple applications so Sherlock
the technology is still we think its
infancy we're working with many
collaborators to continue pushing the
platform forward and if you're all
interested in using the platform either
for academic or commercial use please
reach out to us because we are working
on creating a large portfolio of
resources for people to use the tests
which they think can be incredibly
useful for the community so with that
we'd like to thank all the people who
are involved with this work and made it
possible this is a picture of the Jean
lab at the Broad Institute and we know
this to be impossible without our mentor
from John who created an incredible
environment for this and who was
instrumental in every step of the
process for crane the Sherlock
technology but of course we also want to
thank that people who
helped us at the bench max kalanor and
Jeremy ku and Patrick Bickler three
masters students and Jeremy is a
research associate who were vital in
helping out with the actual development
of the Sri Lanka ecology as well as our
many collaborators Jim Collins who
initially helped us with the element of
the fundamental Sherlock test party
sabeti who saw helped us with many
infectious disease fire applications
Deborah hung who has been instrumental
in vector occupations and Eugene Koonin
and chair Makarova from his lab who have
been very helpful with our exploration
of biodiversity trap this so with that
I'd like to thank you all for listening
well thank you gentlemen for that
informative presentation and I would
also like to be glaber's for today's
educational webcast possible and as a
final reminder your speakers will follow
up with any questions you submitted
that's all for now thank you for joining
us we hope to see you again soon goodbye